if you were to look at the current uh
system that we have we typically ask
this one question I'm curious to know
what your answer is going to be guy
asked me this question yes I'm like you
know no one's ever asked me the question
that I've asked others I asked Joe Rogan
this question out of the five
uh uh organizations and individuals I'll
give you tell me who's got the most
power president of the United States
virtual governments which is you know
Facebook YouTube Twitter all those guys
we call them virtual government and then
you got the educational system you got
mainstream Media or you got the
billionaires in order of top five who
would you put as the most powerful and
the least powerful one more time
president virtual government
educational system mainstream media
billionaires
so it's I think it's relatively easy
billionaires have the most power by an
order of magnitude a way way way more
the president has the least Power by an
order of magnitude because politicians
are basically servants uh they they're
waiters and waitresses that the
mainstream media does marketing for uh
they take an order hey a donor would
like this and they execute the order
okay I will pass a bill in favor of the
donors so why did for example why did
Ted Cruz turn around on a dime oh I'm
gonna get Trump I can't believe he said
that about my wife and I'm gonna get him
and he said that about my dad and he's
on dishonorable man and then he's like
I'm gonna phone beg for Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump please really like
Donald Trump okay True Story by the way
100 True a he's a [ __ ] okay uh but B
let me explain to you why he's a [ __ ]
because when he gave the speech at the
convention and did not endorse Trump he
then went up to his daddy right which is
Robert Mercer that's his donor that gave
him 13 million dollars look again we're
businessman Patrick somebody gives you
13 million dollars they expect something
in return okay especially in politics in
business they expect a return in
politics what do they expect they still
expect a return
but through corruption okay so when when
he goes up to the turn on investment
exactly when he goes up to the suite of
the mercies Robert and Rebecca they
slammed a door in his face they got a
new boy it's Donald Trump and Ted Cruz
miscalculated because he lost his donor
that's why he was like oh I'm sorry in
some my wife all you're like I know I
never really she's not that pretty
anyway you're right she's ugly Donald
Trump what do you need me to do okay
because he is that's who they are they
so the president barely has any power
when when the donors tell uh Biden
you're not gonna pass the 15 minimum
wage shut up and do as you're told Biden
says yes sir absolutely sir I can prove
it I forced the vote The Young Turks did
a petition that forced Bernie to
introduce 15 minimum wage in the Corona
virus relief bill they had it in there
originally they took it out and they
were never going to vote on it why
because it was going to be embarrassing
to the Democrats then Bernie does do the
vote he did the right thing wonderful
okay guess what it wasn't just
Republicans eight Democrats voted
against it including the two Delaware
Senators the two Delaware senators are
not voting without checking with Biden
there is top allies that is Biden saying
I didn't mean it I was lying the whole
time I'm against 15 minimum wage the
whole time pretending that he's in favor
of it if you watch mainstream media they
tell you Joe Biden's in favor of the 15
minimum wage no it was a lie so
mainstream media second most powerful on
that list but they're also servants the
the wealthy or at the top corporations
are at the top everyone else serves them
okay the educational system
that's how that is a variety so because
it has a history right and sometimes
exactly sometimes it's wonderful like in
the 1950s and 60s education in New York
was the best in the world and it
produced uh amazing businessmen
entertainers you name it right so they
uh when I was growing up we had great
Public Schools I went to a public school
in New Jersey right now it's an absolute
disaster in places like California why
because they lowered the tax base and
they privatize the schools and they
funnel the money to private schools and
they starve the public schools so the
educational system is important because
that's where we teach culture now the
right wing would agree with me that we
teach culture there but we disagree on
what we should teach so you put
education three uh I I think education
three uh presidents five so who what's
left what was the digital media virtual
guys oh no my bad virtual government is
is uh now now you're thinking about no
no no no no no they're number three yeah
but they're almost at number two so you
got billionaires the top yeah then you
got Legacy Media number two then and
then virtual governments digital media
number three that's right educational
system number four and at the bottom of
the totem pole the president United
States definitely so here's how I have
it okay uh I have president at the
bottom just like you do I don't think
president is you got eight years what
are you going to be doing and quite
frankly eight years you gotta have
Congress on your side Cindy there's a
lot of moving parts for you to be able
to do a lot of things done and they're
funding you from the back so you're
working for you guys agree uh that part
I agree absolutely at the at the second
to the lowest I put mainstream media
because mainstream media is a byproduct
of the money guys meaning
mainstream media is nobody without the
funders which is billionaires
billionaires make mainstreams whatever
we're talking about so I put mainstream
media at Fourth I put billionaires at
third I put educational system at second
because it's got a long life span kind
of like what you were talking about so
if one side of the political party gets
the educational system you got him for
decades so if you got for every one
conservative Professor 12 or you know on
the liberal side you got a monopoly
there that's a full-on monopoly so
that's problematic because you're able
to indoctrinate younger generation
coming up that's a lot of power that's
number two and I put number one at
virtual government because I think those
guys are becoming just as powerful as
the government if not bigger uh you know
they can do a lot of different things
they can have a lot of control over
other things and you have to go through
them they're not going away so you can
do a lot of things you want to do but
you kind of have to go through them the
virtual governments but you put
billionaires at the Top If you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]